hi there steve kaufman here again to
talk about language learning
[Music]
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe
uh you can tap on the little bell or
click on the little bell here
to get notifications and do come and
join me at link
to learn languages uh today i want to
talk about something that comes up quite
often
and i was thinking about it this evening
and i'll tell you why i was thinking
about it so here i am
normally at the beginning of the week i
get my new mp3 files
from uh this person
in tunisia who gets these mp3 files
from the al jazeera website because i
haven't figured out how to do it myself
so i just
pay her a little bit of money she does
it i get them
i put them on happy scribe and i've got
three new podcasts to study about some
event in the middle east
i haven't got them yet so i'm bored uh
i can go over the old um
[Music]
you know lessons that i've gone over
before but that's not very interesting
although it's good for me um i don't
really want to do that this evening
so i start doing some flashcards now i'm
not a big fan of doing flashcards um
seems to it just takes longer i like
lists or at least that's what i've said
but
you know what i find is i don't i don't
really want to read
the old the text that i have maybe i'm
tired of going through my lists
so i go and do some flash cards and it's
new it's different
and it's enjoyable so i'm connected to
the language
i'm doing something different it
introduced
variety and and it sort of dawned on me
that
variety is so important to our
language learning people ask me how do
you stay motivated well i have to have
variety for a while i was doing
persian and arabic there's some variety
uh i occasionally go back to my mini
stories
and then i go to my more interesting
podcast there there's some variety
i don't really want to plow through the
old texts uh
and maybe even when i get my new uh
podcast
maybe i want to do some more flash
gardening because it's a different thing
to do
it's a different activity keeps me
connected uh with the language
and we know too that the way the brain
learns the brain likes variety
i always quote manfred spitzer the brain
likes repetition
but the brain likes variety variety
novelty
new things uh you know i'll i'll listen
to a podcast
you know i'm subscribed to these
podcasts but i don't know how to
download the mp3 file
but i listen to a new podcast in arabic
while doing the dishes
even though i don't understand much of
it because it's new
like new is good variety is good doing
different things is good
and we know the brain through the work
of
robert bjork of ucla and others the
brain doesn't learn very well when it's
constantly trying to learn and master
the same thing
the brain learns better when it can
meander and
cover the same ground in different ways
so you're coming across
the vocabulary in context but you're
tired of reading so you cover some of
the vocabulary in
flashcards and there's even a variety of
flashcards
you know it can be a reverse flashcard
or a dictation or a closed test or a
multiple choice
so again you're covering some of this
same material in different ways
so variety is good and i just
it's just a quickie video here i thought
i would share that with you i was
enjoying it i
i often say i mean i'm not going to go
through you know
flash guards for 50 000 words that i
have saved in arabic
because then that would be sort of
tedious doing the same thing over and
over and over again
but as a break here i am i've finished
dinner i've
you know done the dishes and i want to
spend a little time with my arabic i'm
supposed to be doing this 90-day
challenge and i'm kind of tired of the
other activities
so i started a new activity which i
haven't been doing flash cards
variety is good variety maintains the
motivation
variety keeps the brain fresh so that's
the message here
make sure you maintain enough variety in
your activities and in the subject
matter
and the places you study and and and and
so forth
uh it's good for the brain and it keeps
you motivated okay
thank you bye
[Music]